members of the labor committee if you
would mind please stand Vice chairman
seaworth would you lead us in the Pledge
of Allegiance
America and to the Republic for which it
stands one nation under God indivisible
thank you very much for all of you for
coming I appreciate it it's on a Friday
we're going to as as representative
Sullivan knows I like to have
free-flowing discussions whenever
possible especially in a situation where
we're talking about retained bills
so uh we'll obviously be less formal uh
speak as you feel free we can have it
not so much a debate between each other
but it's good to have a uh free-flowing
discussion and if there is a discussion
uh I will gladly have a a back and forth
with representative Cahill on anything
he'd like to do and and whatever and
that's can be positive for everybody so
representative Sullivan
just to um be clear
when we spoke about these retained bills
with the Democratic caucus I encouraged
everyone to come if they wanted to but
the members of this uh
work group
um you know the chairman indicated that
he wanted to have three Republicans and
three Democrats on this so the three who
are really members of the work group are
representative Leclair representative
Bouchard and representative Cahill and
they'll be doing the uh the three bills
um in the morning so they will be the
group for all three bills and in the
afternoon for the OSHA Bill it'll be
myself representative soucy and
representative McKenzie so just so I
mean there may be people coming and
going I think it's helpful to know what
people's role are
um so uh that that's those are the roles
in perhaps Mr chairman you can tell us
how the Republicans are
divided up on this
I would if I did if I knew
um we had a lot of people unable to come
at the last couple a couple days so
um
foreign
you indicated that you wanted to have
I
I did not want to pinpoint I apologize
I'm not trying to be coy or anything I I
uh some of the folks that are here today
um
will be here for some and others will
come in as others and and I'm quite
frankly with some of the emails back and
forth I'm not sure who's going to be
present today
when it comes time to
um try to figure out what how we move
forward it would help I mean we've
designated three people for each bill
um it'd be good if
at some point you could designate three
three Republicans who would be uh
teaming up with our fine Democratic
members to figure things out so um
figure it out Mr chairman representative
Cahill I just have a suggestion perhaps
the uh tried and true eenie meeny miny
mo
CK okay
I will I will as we uh after this first
one I will I know kind of who's going to
do what representative uh
love and kolkum are doing a few things
and um so Robert and Granger and uh
I wanted to support another one and so I
will make sure that I have your your
list quite frankly I'm I was kind of
waiting to see who was going to show up
because like I'll be honest with you
Leno uh abalani called me and said well
I can't make it I have a guy out I'm
gonna make it late you know and Leno's
the one who's who's going to be uh an
eye on the OSHA so
again not trying to be coy but I do
respect that you're
so the first bill we have on the docky
here for 10 o'clock is House Bill 190
relative to the duration of unemployment
benefits
and you know this bill came to us and it
the unemployment rate at the time so the
unemployment rate were lower than a
certain amount then there would be fewer
weeks allotted to the individual uh for
unemployment
higher the unemployment rate
higher the the number of
weeks available to the employee
I think we all agree that there were
problems with the Way It Was Written the
department had some issues at how they
would
manage this being that as you know we
calculated
based on two sets of surveys every month
one two businesses and one to employees
themselves
and that sometimes those are not
exact they're perfect and have to be
revised the following month based on
additional information and it'll be very
difficult on a monthly basis with people
maybe on unemployment for one month and
then get a job and be offer a couple and
then maybe add another
um
that it wasn't tenable so in speaking
with the representative
turcotte he was
floating the idea
of
decreasing the amount the week's number
of weeks of benefits
from 26 to 22
but increasing the
benefit
New Hampshire has a relatively low
benefit that is provided
and that
that was what some kind of a compromise
while reducing the weeks by four is
belief is that um
the charts that are provided
a vast majority of people on
unemployment
are
bind employment
within the first two or three months but
there's a certain percentage that wait
till that that last
that last three or four weeks it's like
eight or ten percent weight
till the end
um
we had discussions as to why that occurs
but that is where the intent of the
representative is at this point so I'll
no worries
uh
you mentioned so that uh did you mean on
on people who are going through the
unemployment process wait till the end
to get a job is that what you were I
just want to make sure I understand you
if you look at the the charts of how
long people stay on how many weeks on
average not on average how many weeks
people have unemployment obviously the
first three or four weeks is higher than
it goes It goes down and the curve
continues to go down and then it kind of
spikes the last two weeks interesting
well I can say
um in terms of the notion of a waiting
time all of the requirements because I
have been unemployed twice in the last
10 years and I don't think this part has
changed
um
you you cannot wait to look for work you
have to every week to receive any of the
unemployment assistance you have to uh
can not only agree
uh in your in your agreements that you
do weekly there is a notice that you
check that says uh I am continuing to
look for work and then you are supposed
to report at least two of those and the
assumption is you're doing way more than
two of those I can't I can't explain
what a blip at the end would mean other
than as you know I'm in a field that
doesn't have a ton of workers so
that could be one of those I mean some
people just are in jobs that don't have
a lot of openings for one reason or
another at certain points in our economy
but they're
again I can't explain the blip but
legally you cannot receive and you agree
that you cannot receive uh if you aren't
actively looking for work every week and
if you stop looking for work for a week
I don't know if you can get back on it
but I do know that you have you're not
allowed to receive it for that week like
I don't know maybe you went to
somebody's wedding out of the state or
something I don't know if you can even
go back on unemployment after that but
if you are not actively looking for week
for work every week and report at least
two employers that you've communicated
with or applied for a job uh just know
that there really isn't a waiting period
I hope that's helpful no I understand
there is a one-week waiting period as we
all know but you are correct there are
certain there are a number of mechanisms
that are required
from vocational training to showing up
to going to get your resume
um worked on to to requiring correct
um you have to look for work you can't
be gone on vacation for a week or two
and you're no doubt you are correct on
all those uh venues one of the other
reasons I I see your hands gentlemen one
of the other reasons
um that I think we determined that some
people wait
a thing called partially unemployed if
you will kind of started the last time
we had a little recession uh for some of
you folks that are new to the
um the committee
it it used to be uh you you can now get
unemployment benefits if you were used
to working 40 hours a week and your
employer says look we're having a we
don't have a lot of work this week I'm
going to bring you down to 20 hours for
the next three weeks I can only give you
20 hours
so there is an ability to get some of
the partial so if you have someone that
is going to you know you know you
doesn't look like it now with a 1.9
unemployment rate but some of us who've
been here long enough on this committee
remember when we had you know a higher
unemployment rate and it wasn't as easy
to find uh find work
um and you would you know employers
might say see you know for the next five
or six months especially during the
winter season or whatever if we're slow
we're not going to be able to give you
that
the full time and so people will do that
and that could be one of the reasons you
have that spike in the end that last
couple weeks that certain people stay on
for a longer period of time so there's
other reasons that are not
nefarious
uh as you know I'm just going to hang
out and we've all heard stories you know
people that well I you know take a
summer off but you know I think those
are few and far between
Bouchard and Cahill please
um thank you
Mr chairman um
fortunately I've never had to go through
that experience
however according to the data that was
given to us
the majority of the people who are
following that category are going
through
the limit are people with disabilities
people who have child care
responsibilities
such as women
and also Elder older workers
and that are have a really difficult
time trying to find a job
I think you should also include in there
if I could expand on what you're saying
representative Bouchard
individuals who may have been
um in an occupation for
the last 25 or 30 years and there's been
changes in that so I will use a machine
shop as an example you're used to using
your hands with a machine shop and now
there really aren't that many machine
shops where you use your hands anymore
and you have to learn a computer skill
because they're CAD based uh computer
screens and the machines do the work
uh and you need more vocational training
because you really can't find one of
those jobs that you used to have because
they're not doing it that way anymore
representative Cahill yeah uh thank you
Mr chairman and I think you and my
colleagues to my right here have covered
most of what I was going to say about
this because the statistics don't get
into the details about the circumstances
it could be that you live in Coos County
and there just aren't as many jobs as
there would be in Hillsborough County or
that like you said yours the skill set
that you have or your age you're a Gray
I'm with you brother to uh you know the
employer and uh so there's a lot of
factors but I what I don't think is is a
problem is that our benefits are too
generous or so generous to the point
where people are kicking back and just
saying I had everything I need on you
know
on this uh amount of money that the
state pays me and I don't I'm not going
to bother looking I don't I don't think
we I don't think the bill is really
focused on an area that we need
attention to
in speaking with the uh assistant
commissioner
I asked
if a couple times a year he or other
members of his staff go on these
I don't know what you call them uh they
all meet people chairman and vice
chairman will meet from somewhere across
the country with other uh excuse me uh
yes thank you it was a convention but a
conference and they get together and
they go to these conferences they say is
there anything you've learned that other
states have done that you could bring
back that has to do with that last those
people that are hanging on that last
couple weeks and he actually quite
frankly felt that New Hampshire was kind
of ahead of the curve on a lot compared
to a lot of their their counterparts in
other states we are a little more
aggressive than others in helping people
get
back and there really wasn't anything in
any of these conferences that they had
gone to where they had seen anything
that any other state had come up with it
was
that great and wonderful that we should
adopt representative Sullivan oh Lord
Sullivan yeah okay Brian representative
that's a worth the other Brian
thank you Mr chairman uh so my concern
here is I'm not sure what we're trying
to solve
um so for example I think everyone here
would agree that our goal is not to
spend as little money as possible
um is our goal to get people back to
work the fastest that's one of the
metrics that we tout but as you just
explained that isn't necessarily the
best thing if someone needs to be
retrained in a computer skill that they
never had it might take more time to do
that so
um
and I I think that is the right starting
point talking to the department and
saying what are we doing right what have
you seen done elsewhere that might be
better
this approach feels like kind of a shot
in the dark that well maybe things would
be better if we
cut the weeks by this much and it's not
I don't see what we're trying to
accomplish and therefore how this is
getting us there it more seems like just
a thing to try that
could help
um for myself I I would need to start
with that goal and that
approach that's going to achieve that
goal rather than simply
let's try something that might help no I
agree that's why I had asked the
assistant commissioner about these
conferences is there anything else we're
not doing to tag you're right if you're
going to solve the problem
solve the problem don't create something
that's not solving anything that's just
um
uh try to find out that last
10 percent
of the clerk yeah thank you
so you mentioned the possibility of
increasing the benefit
who does that is that does it is the Des
totally in charge of what it is or and
then it comes before the house
legislature okay and and if so I mean
what would be the thought process and uh
a percentage or you know kind of cost of
living type thing or
I mean I don't how do we have any idea
how long it's been at where it is now
20 years Brian I think it's probably I
I've been here almost 20 years and it's
been the second time off but you know up
here and uh I I don't I think it has
been done in 20 years
do you remember when the last time it
it's been a long time and and um so that
might be something just initially to to
get the ball rolling and to find out how
long it's been maybe do a couple of
colas or however it's typically gone up
and kind of figure it out from there I
mean personally I don't I don't mind the
26 weeks it's been that way for a long
time as well so I'm usually that's only
the state you know the federal
government also in certain times has
adds other other benefits on
um when they see fit
representative Sullivan
thank you the um
I
I guess um the horse trade of uh
increase in benefits in exchange for
decreasing weeks
um you know it it's a little too vague
for me
um
and then I guess the other thing you
know I just opened the uh
booklet that the Deputy Commissioner
brought to us to describe where we're at
and it's too small to uh see everything
but the green on this map
26 weeks
all of New England except for Rhode
Island has got 26 weeks
they probably also receive a higher
level of benefits than New Hampshire
because we're we're definitely on the
low side so for us to give up weeks in
exchange for gaining ground on the other
New England states with regard to
benefits doesn't seem to make a whole
lot of sense
um and
um so I I just doesn't doesn't make
sense to me Rhode Island by the way has
got 30 weeks so um it it um
and I guess if if representative
turcotte has a new plan
um I would expect that he would have
been here to present it to us but
obviously he is not
um so I'm the friendly Skies uh I I I I
I I would recommend that we do nothing
with this
um and um perhaps uh
some one of us ought to look at uh
um the level of benefits and see if it
does warrant increasing it but I don't
think it warrants an increase in
thank you Mr chair on the subject of
raising the benefits it's not for lack
of trying I I think I've seen a few of
those bills in recent years and it also
seems sort of counter-intuitive to what
Representatives turcott's goal you know
I'll give you more money and if he's
thinking that we're already giving them
too much money I'm not sure this uh
holds up
but uh I do think that with the uh
unemployment people have a variety of
incentives for uh employers as well they
offer to help pay for training or to or
to make up the wage difference uh they
have a very good programs to help people
get back to work if there's anything
else that we might do for coordinating
with industry and the and the department
I think that would be helpful of course
having more people of working age is
another good step if we can find a way
to do that but I don't think I could
support this bill
um I believe unless another state has
lowered their rates we Remain the lowest
in the nation
um
and
I will oppose this bill as well and I
could say a few other things but I'll
real dragon ah Ranger sorry
look at it Mike think of you sorry
we got two of them but
um so I actually like the idea of the
bill and the reason I like the idea of
the bill is you know maybe I break from
a lot of the members here but I actually
do think that a responsible governance
requires that we spend as little
taxpayer dollars as possible and seeing
as they cannot give any unemployment
benefits to anybody unless they take it
from somebody else I would like to
reduce the amount that they're taking
altogether and so if this can result in
less spending overall then I would
going way back uh I think maybe in the
70s or so the Massachusetts had a
program where you could get an extension
and it was for times of extreme
unemployment you know and I I don't know
what the numbers were whether they were
seven eight nine percent whatever uh
if we tax something like that onto this
you know where we reduce but if we hit a
um you know a a point where you know
where there's a lot of unemployment and
it's hard to get jobs uh you know you
could you could get a six-week extension
or whatever
um how would uh how would people feel
boy you put me on the spot how do I feel
I
just just a thought that's what the
any other
comments
all right seeing none
um
for the record uh the three individuals
all right
okay I'm going to close the hearing and
give you two minutes and then we'll
um Brian
refresh my memory is an excellent uh
uh the firefighter one or the uh
cannabis
Pizza
you know
representative Sullivan the three
Republicans for the next bill House Bill
82 FN relative to employment protection
for participants in their back
therapeutic
cannabis program is love Qualcomm and
infantine
right sorry
and in ours are the same three K Hill
Bouchard and LeClaire and by the way
Dan's name is Leclair
the sea is silent
good I I learned that when I spent uh
almost 20 years up in the north country
with the uh the French Canadians in
Berlin so
so the house bill 82 FN relatives are
employment protection for participants
in therapeutic cannabis program uh had
its impetus from a New Hampshire Supreme
that
um
was injured
is provided I'm sorry to try to pull up
the build
uh was um
let go because they were utilizing
therapeutic cannabis for their injury
and the Supreme Court said no uh it is
law you're allowed to do it and so we
had a number of conversations about
the uh Supreme Court ruling
what it said
what it meant what we should do and
there were some uh disagreements well
I'm not going to say anything and um so
there were some questions and some
concerns about the bill and that's why
we had retained it so it's open for
discussion representative Sullivan if
you'd like or representative seaworth if
you'd like either one of you gentlemen
can start
I'm happy to start
um
Mr chairman you know that we've had
conversations on the phone on this issue
and um at one point
um you know the discussion had been
um over
um current employees who get a
therapeutic cannabis card in the course
of employment and then the new employee
who is just being hired with a
therapeutic cannabis card and um uh you
had suggested that perhaps we could
cover the the uh the current employees
in
um
allow discrimination against the the
prospective employees and the way I
answered that is that all types of
discrimination cover
employees through the hiring process and
through the course of employment and I I
just can't Envision can't support
dividing that out with this issue
if you know you can't discriminate
against someone because of their race
their religion their gender at the point
of hire or throughout their the course
of employment and on this issue I would
suggest that we need to do the same that
Bar discrimination through the on the
hiring process as well as through the
course of employment so um I feel
strongly that way
representative Holcomb
oh
I'm sorry I didn't know
thank you Mr chairman so
um you had mentioned the Supreme Court
ruling that was a discussion that you
and I had uh and it was one of my
concerns with the language of the bill
it was brought up in uh testimony a
number of times that the driver for this
was that the law is not consistent with
what the Supreme Court ruling was so I
dug out the Supreme Court ruling and
tried to figure out what it said
and
it is a little different than what I had
anticipated from the discussion about it
the Supreme Court ruling does not say
that you can't fire someone with a
medical marijuana card or even you can't
fire someone because
of a medical marijuana issue what it
says is that
um you have to treat it like
any other workplace accommodation
so that
um
someone has a medical marijuana card and
the employer can still say all right
here's what I will do to accommodate
that person uh maybe anything from
adjusting their schedule when they might
be medicated or or maybe changing their
duties from something that might be at
risk for a federal license or whatever
but like uh
other workplace accommodations it
doesn't simply say that you must it says
that you must weigh the cost of that
accommodation
um
with your your business needs so
that was my concern with the language is
that I felt like the language in the
build didn't match the areas of the law
that the Supreme Court
decision went down
and um
I asked for it to be interim study
because I I thought it might be more
appropriate to match those two scenarios
thank you Mr chairman
um my position unfortunately is the
complete opposite of Representative
Sullivan and we really are on on
opposite ends on this one
um and where there's discussion
regarding the discrimination and that we
shouldn't have discrimination
unfortunately with the amendment that
was put through there is outlined in
discrimination in this and that we have
carved out specific positions that would
be exempt
um from the non-hiring process such as
the police the fire the health care
federal DOT there are specific positions
exempt that would prohibit employers
from hiring these people if they were to
test positive solely for cannabis and I
don't think we should be either we take
out all exemptions or we allow the
employers to make a decision based on
the risk factors of their jobs that are
available I still feel strongly that we
should not be having impaired
electricians HVAC mechanics drivers who
do not require a DOL card
um
and and other people that are using high
risk equipment and other high-risk
positions that we have those employers
should be able to make a decision
of who they're going to hire and they
don't know that when they're offering
the job and they're placing this passing
of a drug screening as a contingency of
offer
so we either take all positions out and
we do not discriminate as representative
Sullivan pointed out or we do allow
comes out of love oh I'm sorry gentlemen
I'll get you after representative love
Bouchard and Cahill
uh right here uh you know I've always
argued about the the workplace accidents
and stuff uh you know regarding this and
uh this here says
positive marijuana test following work
workplace accidents are the highest in
25 years okay because states are
adopting this I don't think New
Hampshire should be following it fallen
into that that trap uh you know
workplace accidents uh
let's face it that it's horrible you
know uh you know I've I've had to
collect workers comp and it's it's no
picnic you know being being hurt and
laying there in bed and uh you know
unable to to uh to earn a living and
then come back and you can only do half
the job and uh we've got to avoid that
at all costs and um you know just
I can't I can't put my my stamp of
approval on on anything that uh you know
it was gonna uh make things worse
it was a Bouchard
thank you Mr chairman
um I just want to focus the idea that
this is a medication
with a prescription
and
when you follow the prescription you are
not impaired
and basically what people are discussing
about is people who are abusing
the drug and that's another issue
how I look at this bill is it just
addresses that you cannot discriminate
against someone
for their prescription drug
for employment thank you Mr kale
Mike once again representative Bouchard
has preempted my discussion
I gotta get my hand up faster next time
I'll start going Bouchard perfect thank
you so much alphabetically and
challenged so again yeah the bill does
not provide anyone anyone can be
impaired on the job
and I think if you if you were abusing
alcohol or or anything else and you your
employer judged you to be impaired that
would be grounds for dismissal or
certain you know if you show up for an
interview and you
you uh you're drunk I don't think that
prospects are good but it is a
medication and I'm gonna we're moving
toward legalization so I I think a lot
of this testing other than for those
positions where we seem to we we agree
that uh you know any any degree of uh
use of this would pose a risk I think
where the tests are going to go away
but for now certainly where you have a a
prescription because it helps you with
pain uh perhaps you want prior injury uh
and it helps you get a good night's
sleep so that you can function at work
and you're not impaired uh I I think
this is I think this is something we
should pass
like
version of Granger
followed by did you
um Draco did I see your hand up no
representative Granger followed by love
thank you Mr Speaker um so this seems
like a freedom issue to me
um I believe that ultimately I believe
in Freedom of Association and so that
means that just as somebody has the
right to use marijuana if they want
someone else has right not to associate
with that as a result and you know I I
wouldn't just apply this marijuana I'd
apply this to any prescription drug and
even though it's very unlikely that
someone's going to be uh discriminated
against for using ibuprofen I believe
that that is a right and a freedom that
you have the right to do just as it is
your right to use ibuprofen and
therefore I would uh I would oppose this
bill because I'd support the right uh to
associate with whomever you please
because we we cannot measure any degree
of impairment there's there's no tests
available
um you know what I think we'll end up
with uh
if if there is an accident uh the
employer will be sitting there saying
you know you were stoned and the
employees say no I wasn't yes you were
no you weren't uh we're opening a can of
worms that we shouldn't be opening
um the the employer has to be able to
say I don't like your job performance
you know since you've been on this stuff
uh
and you know and be able to to let that
person go if he has to uh or change it
changes occupation uh you know if you if
you're making thirty dollars an hour and
uh you know your job performance isn't
so good and that employer should have
the right to at least say you've got to
do this job over here and you're only
going to get 20.
um you know um we we can't be
we can't be telling employers how to run
the how to run their business uh like
that you know the safety issues hit
and and in the end this the employer is
liable
you know
representative kale uh thank you Mr
chair uh I don't believe the employer is
barred from dismissing or disciplining a
someone who's a who's negative
performance is is you just can't do it
because
you have a prescription card
so if if I'm taking uh Thorazine and uh
it's affecting my performance you could
still you could still say well this
isn't working anymore and if I go to the
labor board and you can you tell me you
warned me and and that my performance
software you cite examples I'm going to
lose
so it shouldn't be any different there's
no I understand about the impairment and
as far as the roadside testing and
everything but if you're working with
someone on a day-to-day basis and you
see that they're
they seem to be off I I think you have a
reasonable presumption that uh this
could be a part of it and have a
conversation but with the employee if
the employee is able to address that and
maybe adjust their dosage or the time
that they uh take the use the cannabis
it can be worked out I think employees
are too valuable now that we shouldn't
be denying them because of something
that they are medically
prescribed and I think in again in the
future is going to be something that is
uh
that is there and legal for anybody
I'm gonna I'm gonna I I want to
interject at this point I appreciate the
the passion
um
but we as as I brought up in the
executive session we need to get back
to we're off on all these tangents about
being stoned at work and being this that
and the other let's get back to what
representative combination of what what
the representatives Brian's have to have
said
um
this as we all know there are rules
about discrimination
at the workplace we also know that
there's this accommodation that can be
made if someone has a situation let's
just take away drugs for a second okay
someone has a stroke someone breaks
their legs there's a terrible motorcycle
accident breaks their leg okay they can
no longer do
um what they were doing
can the employer make a reasonable
accommodation whether it's a certain
workstation or a certain chair or a
certain whatever to allow that
individual to continue to work the
federal government has said you must as
an employer make a reasonable
accommodation
okay now
what is reasonable well you know all
depends it's going to cost me as an
employer a thousand dollars to buy you a
better workstation where you can stand
up and sit down and bring your keyboard
up to your chest and do whatever or or
work at a on a assembly line and certain
things
um is it going to cost you a thousand
dollars to make that a reasonable
accommodation or is it going to cost you
uh 25 000 to make that reasonable
accommodation and then you can discuss
whether what is reasonable what is not
so this thing came from a situation
where we had a Supreme Court ruling and
Brian Sullivan is correct uh seaworth is
correct this was about reasonable
accommodation so let's bring it back
down to what this was
it a reasonable accommodation
to allow this individual to take
therapeutic cannabis
to be and and to be working and it was
about a drug test
okay let's bring it back narrow again as
to what the Supreme Court ruling it's
nice having a Supreme Court Justice
former Supreme Court Justice to state
representative because I went over the
ruling with him so what does it say and
what does this doesn't doesn't say okay
so following again bring this thing down
narrow again
it said they must make a reasonable
accommodation
okay then you have to go to 126 x
okay which is our
therapeutic cannabis law
okay so you have to look at what it does
what it says what it doesn't say and you
cannot be under the you you have a so
bring it down to the drug test
okay I have to provide you a reasonable
accommodation and I cannot fire you if
you test positive for a drug test it
doesn't say you can be under the
influence on the job it doesn't say you
can have it in your possession
in the workplace
it doesn't say these things okay so part
of the reasonable accommodation
from a safety standpoint because you
know hey I'm workers comp guy here right
you know dream and sleep you know
workers comp it's crazy
um
you don't want because the workers
compensation can deny a claim
if you are impaired
if you were drunk
um if you are under alcohol trust me
I've had case cases where someone got
killed
and boy that drug test was not something
anyone wanted to go to court about
okay and so
bring you down again here you cannot be
have it on your pocket you can't be
smoking pot at work you can't be under
the influence
where bring it down to what the Supreme
Court
said in their ruling where I disagree
with representative Sullivan on this is
and I I see where it's coming from and I
respect where he's coming from I don't
agree in this case
you don't want discrimination
okay this is about an occurring employee
making accommodation this is not about
making accommodations or making things
for employees that have not been hired
yet to allow them to get hired and
that's the only place we disagree and
representative colcom isn't politics
great when you're trying to trying to
make
um trying to to make law where you don't
want discrimination but we've already
discriminated because fire police and
emergency because they don't want it
they don't want this and they don't want
that in their ranks okay so we're gonna
we're gonna exclude something
so yeah welcome to the world of trying
to make a a a bill that works for
everybody uh or a law that works for
everybody so I would I I wish I you know
it isn't I would like to pass a law
that is consistent with what the United
States New Hampshire Supreme Court said
because if we don't we look foolish the
Supreme Court has overruled us in their
jurisdiction as a judicial branch of our
three branches we're the legislative
branch
okay
I don't you know normally we kind of
should listen to what they say and kind
of bring the law into Conformity I guess
we could do the opposite
we could look at their ruling
and say you're full of full of water
we're going to put another bill in
that takes away
the authority of your ruling and makes
it no longer null and void because of a
new law not sure we need to do that
either
but those are the things in front of us
so representative love I respect the
fact that you don't want people to be
under the influence of work that's not
what the bill allows it's about a
reasonable accommodation
uh and and so I'm happy to have this big
broad discussion but just try to bring
it back to where it is and I will also
say one last thing
we are all well aware
of what kind of a legislature we have
it's a good legislature because it's
very close it's very divided so you get
the best of all legislation something on
either well no something you do some of
the stuff on on one way side on that
side isn't going to pass on that way
side that side's not going to pass all
right because we if you don't have the
votes if you do have the votes for the
house and you got to go to the Senate
so if we do pass a bill which I would
like to a very narrowly focused Bill
based on the Supreme Court based on the
accommodations based on all these things
I would like to pass something out of
the house that's going to pass in the
Senate
so keep that in mind that uh passing
something out of one body that has no
chance in the other bodies
it makes a point but sometimes it's a
waste of time as well so
I said
very little with too many words but
let's kind of keep it narrow and get it
back to what the Supreme Court ruling is
and um and the accommodation of aspect
representative Qualcomm
followed by Solomon and love
thank you Mr chairman so I would like to
share that I am
I'm prepared to fully support this bill
if we can put an amendment through that
takes out just the piece of the new hire
and leave everything else as it is but
take out the piece of the new hire and I
will absolutely compromise and support
this bill
I agree and I've relayed that to
representative Sullivan in a very polite
and cordial the way he and I always talk
on the phone and we haven't had a
meeting in the minds yet but I do
understand and I support what you're
saying representative Sullivan and then
low
thank you
and and I do respect the perspective of
my Republican uh friends
um
with regard to the Supreme Court uh case
Supreme Court case dealt with the
um the specific
facts of a single case that individual
happened to be employed at the time that
the issue arose that's why the Supreme
Court only dealt with currently employed
individuals they never liked to broaden
the decision to cover all kinds of other
issues that aren't presently before them
I would anticipate that if there is a
new case where someone was discriminated
against at the point point of higher
because solely because they have a
therapeutic cannabis card I think they
would also say that's not okay either
but I agree this Supreme Court case
doesn't deal with that issue but I
believe this bill should
um so um
you know it
just Supreme Court cases don't
necessarily Drive legislation it
justifies this legislation just to a
certain degree but I I continue to
believe that this ought to cover people
at the point of higher and during the
course of employment thank you
representative love followed by Sullivan
uh seaworth why am I doing that
[Laughter]
thank you
um
just like representative kolkum you know
I I I I I don't like the idea of uh you
know the the government jumping into who
you can hire and who you can't you know
and who you can refuse to hide
um also the the Supreme Court ruling
doesn't get it it doesn't give the the
employer any rights at all
um you know it more or less takes away
uh if if an amendment uh came forth that
would uh allow an employer to uh to say
okay you can't do this job
but you can do this one and you're going
to get ten dollars an hour less or
whatever uh you know uh give the
employer back some a little a little
power in this uh because once again if
if somebody's uh even a little bit
uh you know stoned don't choose the word
what it is I um you know it could affect
you know the the job safety of many
and um if uh if somebody's operating say
a forklift operator in a warehouse okay
uh you know you don't want somebody
that's impaired and um you know so now
you give them a broom and say here clean
the place but you're not going to get
that wage shoot uh if we had if we had
an amendment to do that I'd be okay
thank you very much representative C
worth thank you Mr chairman uh
my fellow Brian brought up a point
um about Supreme Court rulings in the
law that
uh I haven't worked on another committee
besides labor but to me it seems like
labor in some ways is different and
that's part of the reason why
this bill was bought forward and part of
the reason why it is necessary to
um have us align with what the Supreme
Court already said is the difference in
what would happen right now if someone
violates the Supreme Court an employer
violates the Supreme Court ruling the
employee can take that case to court and
almost certainly any Court will use the
Supreme Court ruling as president
what they can't do is go to the labor
department who follows the laws that we
write for them so to me the importance
of
uh backing a Supreme Court ruling might
be more uh in in this committee than
some other committees and that's so that
future employees who find themselves in
the same boat and would have a case in
the courts don't have to undergo that
expense because we've told the labor
department
to follow the same rules that the courts
would and that's neither that's not an
argument to put more or less or take
something out but I to me that was an
important
message about what we're trying to do
here with this bill
put all the respect to my colleague uh
representative love uh I I object to the
characterization of people on medical
marijuana or stoned uh it is a term that
is used to um
you know to suggest that somebody is is
impaired and that's not necessarily the
case
let me also say uh TV just a tad is that
Miracle Medical Marijuana will be
introduced uh in the workers comp
environment
No Doubt
it'll be used as part of a cocktail
um of therapy that is be available to
people uh to return them to work it
already is and so the idea that somebody
can't get in the door and no disrespect
you uh representative but the idea they
can't get in the door
but they can use these kinds of um this
kind of uh therapy to return to work and
in fact save the employer considerable
amount of money because they've been
able to go back to work so I think this
has I I think when we look at at medical
marijuana we need to do it in the
context of it is a therapy it is a part
of a therapy and for those who are
injured or those who are trying to
maintain a good life uh I I think it's
it has a place uh in in this uh in this
and I
you know I support the concept of it and
let me say this I you know I was a
firefighter and a captain for a long
time I dealt with a whole lot of people
over the course of my time
and if somebody was impaired they were
going home
that was it and you know they're
impaired uh if you if you're attentive
to what's going on as an officer or as a
manager you know they're impaired
but I never took I never went to a
firefighter the day walked in the door
and said by the way I think you could be
in PH you might possibly be impaired at
some point down the line I took it based
on what I observed as a manager in a in
a in a department so I think it really
turns on impairment and to borrow
somebody from the beginning of their
career to take that away from them to
deny them that opportunity to be able to
be employed in various uh occupations I
think it's harsh
and and I think in the context of where
we are with this treatment program and
the fact that the state is recognizes
that it is part of a program of uh of
restoring people to uh to normalcy and
getting him back to work and getting him
in a position where they can function
well
um so I I would disagree respectfully
with my colleagues uh and i would
support this legislation Mr chairman
from Joseph Cahill you short enough I'm
going to get you before Bouchard
representative Cahill qualified
thank you Mr chair uh again I imagine
that you know you have a job and uh
you're injured at the job you get
Workers Comp and then for whatever
reason you leave the job so now you have
a medical marijuana card
and you're applying for a job and you
can't get it because you have because
you're going to fail the test
I don't think we want that
so I I mean I again as I said earlier I
I think the testing is going to go away
in unless it's the situation where it is
a real real potential risk
so I think we could pass the bill
you know with this amendment that uh
two zero two three oh seven eight five H
and be done with it
in anticipation of us of a Supreme Court
ruling if it should come to pass I think
thank you Mr chairman
um I just would like to respond to the
comments since my name was brought up I
don't I don't disagree with a lot of
what you're saying
um
when an employer has a group of
employees
they've learned what their work ethics
like what their skills are like what
their safety practices are like and
everything else there's a known entity
there and if somebody gets injured or
somebody has to go into therapeutic
cannabis they have some basis to measure
their performance on whether or not it's
been affected they have a relationship
there that they may be willing to
accommodate based off of the
circumstances of the employment many
factors can come into place
with regard to a new hire you're going
on good faith through an interview
process that maybe goes as long as three
hours when you consider the different
people that may be involved in the
interview process so there is no there's
no known Benchmark there's it's all in
good faith it's all in what this
person's it is coming forward with and
of course we all you know make ourselves
sound much better than we actually are
we fake it till we make it when we get
that new job that's been known for Years
everybody comes in that way
I'm not saying that the employee that
we're writing a law that says the
employers must not hire I'm saying that
I don't want to tie their hands and to
take that option away from them based on
the risk factors of the jobs that they
have available
if I have an administrative job that is
low risk my workers comp or on that
person's safety I may say you know what
I'm okay I'm going to take this risk
but when I have a job
with an electrician who's dealing with
high voltage or a crane operator well
they may need a federal again it's a
this is still a federal offense
marijuana is still not legal at the
federal level so we can't even have a
crane operator an HVAC technician who is
working on roofs and also working in
high voltage equipment that may be a
risk I don't want to take because I want
that employee to go home at the end of
the day to his family
so I am just saying that I don't want to
tie the employer's hand I want to leave
it to their discretion at the new hire
process because the new hire process
is still all in good faith based off of
an interview process where we all put
our best foot forward
everything else if they're working there
and and they go into therapeutic
cannabis all that stuff comes out that's
something that's already a relationship
built with that employer and employee
of Granger
uh thank you so going off of that
considering that the unemployment rate
is incredibly low If an employer is
discriminating based on whether or not
someone is uh prescribed to marijuana or
has a medical cannabis card then that's
their loss I don't see how we need to
add to the pile by saying oh it's
illegal to discriminate in that manner
they're losing out on a potentially good
employee if all that you guys are saying
is true that this person is you know
totally capable of doing doing the job
they're not a workplace liability
because they're not abusing the drug
they're merely using it okay then the
punishment in the market for not hiring
that person is you don't have a good
employee it doesn't make any sense to
pile onto that and say well now we're
going to have uh discrimination laws
that prevent you from making a wise
Sound Decision as your best capable of
making such decision that just doesn't
make any sense yeah you need to allow
people to make their own choices you
need to allow people to be free to just
decide to do whatever they're going do
and if it's a mistake that's their
mistake we all have the right to make
mistakes
yeah my dad told me I made a lot um
representative Sullivan in just a point
of order
um it's been a long time since we had
the executive session on uh this bill
and um I had to look myself to figure
out what's the status of this bill we've
had um three votes so far on on this one
the first was to pass the amendment so
the amendment is passed
um the one that representative Cahill
mentioned has passed the committee we
have also had a 10 to 10 vote on otpa
and we've also had a 16-4 vote on retain
so
just
as we come back together we've got to
finish the process
the amendment doesn't need to be voted
on again we've passed it already so
that's that's where we're at so far
I'm gonna make some comments this moment
please
the Supreme Court of New Hampshire has
also stated that
um
sword I'm not gonna not diagnosis uh
the treatment
or workplace injuries can be a doctor
can prescribe medical marijuana okay
insurance companies do have to if a
doctor prescribes it insurance companies
do have to pay for it so that's also
something that's been passed
marijuana is a
part of our environment
I went to a concert last night so I'm
sure with the people around me I'm sure
I probably test positive right now
somewhere
employers have to make
the employers that I deal with will tell
me right now if they drug test
their employees they would lose half
their employees
many many of them are taking marijuana
out of the out of the
uh
off of the
um the not good list I mean it has to be
past marijuana it has to be an opioid of
cocaine has to be something else
before they're not going to hire someone
so they were kind of the the bar has
been been moved and people don't even
consider the marijuana anymore
so we are in an environment that's
changing we all understand that
okay and and we're trying to figure out
these laws with this in new environment
and I don't think anyone around here
I think we all agree that there are
certain very positive medicinal purposes
uh for marijuana the Native Americans
knew something that we didn't a long
time ago
um and um
so
and I only said that because they are
the ones that kind of you know kind of
grew wild in the wild in the west so
anyway
um they the um so I understand this all
these different things that we're trying
to take from society and safety and this
new realm of of therapeutic
um
uses
and all the great things that it can do
for you and and I and I I understand the
struggle here
um
and
something and try to expand it out past
what it is over the years in this
committee we have seen legislation don't
check the box okay no longer have a
boxer if you can be kind of a felony
okay we wanted to get rid of that no
longer can ask this you must know can't
take a you know you can't ask someone to
take or for a credit check
unless a whole list of exclusions except
if you touch money or in charge of money
work for the nuclear power plant blah
blah blah all these other things so
we've seen all these things and just
just think about this for a second maybe
the fact that we have not had all these
things if a lot of employers to do
things that they feel are important for
their businesses which is why we have
such a low unemployment rate
I'm just just throwing that out there
that giving employers the ability to do
what they want to do
guess what they make decisions if
they're going to hire someone with a
felony or not and many of them are
saying that's okay we're going to give
them a chance maybe we're going to take
a drug test but we're not going to
include marijuana in that drug test
anymore because that's okay
and that flexibility so I don't want to
expand things past
um
what they are and I'm going to really
kind of for myself personally adhere
this down to
let's follow what the Supreme Court said
and try to craft legislation as best we
can toward that
um
you want to put another bill in
specifically for lack of discrimination
I would say try to do that but
uh I don't like to to pile on when when
we don't have to representative love and
then I'm going to wrap this up in the
next five minutes for everybody but
everyone obviously you know if you
really need something to say you really
want to say something please feel free
to raise your hand representative love
okay I want to apologize to anybody I I
offended with using the word stoned uh
you know I should have used them paid
and uh you know I not the not the pile
excuses on it I do have a condition
where sometimes I have a hard time
grabbing a word you know I know what I
want to say impaired didn't come to mind
you know it I knew it I should have been
using something else but David we've
been using that word since we were kids
yeah yeah that was the word well that
was the word back then you know I think
I believe there's no one here older than
me I don't think but I actually believe
stoned oh I'm sorry I've been
representative Bouchard you got me I
actually believe the word Stone was
originally a word for being drunk is
the wonderful Ray Charles had a song
Let's go get stoned and it was about
alcohol drinking yes I think anyway
thank you representative love any other
further comments
all right
um we all know where we stand
we all know what we want to get past and
we're all going to have to compromise a
little
to get something passed so we'll take
this into our our next meeting but thank
you uh excellent conversation
where I just had my schedule
moving on to the I call the firefighter
build house bill 182.
uh prohibiting discharge of volunteer
firefighters or volunteer emergency
medical technicians from other
employment
uh this bill has come to us twice it
came to us last session and it was
killed it came to this session we've
modified a bit
um and um has to do with we have
full-time firefighters we have volunteer
firefighters and some of our smaller
communities
and
um
it is important that they're available
um when needed an emergency
wanting to have some protection if an
employee is late to work or unable to
show up to work that they will not be
fired because of
performing that Duty if they are in a
spoken to the head of the fire chiefs
Association about this I know I
contacted the lobbyists
or the association
I know the association had a meeting
um
last week
and
um I
because specifically of that is there
any
comments that would like to be made to
the committee at all
Jody please
I'll be very brief for the record my
name is Jody grimbolis and we represent
the New Hampshire Association of Fire
Chiefs we did bring this up to them in
the past and did bring it to them
recently before their last meeting and
it was decided the time that they're
going to continue to monitor this this
situation they're not taking a position
because they do have individual Chiefs
with different perspectives
so I'll leave it at that
thank you
um obviously the the default the
full-time Fire Chiefs and the chiefs
with the volunteers have a different
perspective on on the law or on the
proposed law and the circumstance so I'm
not going to I'll save my comments for
the end I will open it up
um to anyone's comments uh Vice chairman
I'll get to this earlier rather than
later I'm I'm looking at the
the the score sheet here
um we voted on two amendments in
executive session
um
0990 and 0979 both of those amendments
came to a 10-10 vote so neither of them
passed we also voted on um autopass and
that was an 8-12 vote and the retain was
I'll continue for a second please do
um I
I guess it's it's
um
I guess I feel exactly the way the
police or the fire chiefs do
I don't I I'm not I'm trying to figure
out if this is a bill that we really
need or not
um and they're not sure
and I'm scratching my head because I'm
not sure
um if there's a need I think we should
try to find a way to to address the need
damn oh man
representative seaworth
that was the previous chairman yeah wow
go ahead so I've probably gotten a
little tiresome with my example about
the airline pilot
in part because it is it is a little out
there I don't think it it could ever
happen but since that discussion
um
one thing that has brought been brought
up is about the employee who is a
full-time firefighter
and that that only
can happen I'm sure it does I'm
imagining uh I I know from talking with
our fire people especially the the
younger
um firefighters and and probably some of
the older ones too really like the
larger departments where they can get
the three on four off ships that's very
desirable for a certain segment so
um I am quite sure there are
uh firefighters who live in a smaller
town but work in a nearby City to get a
full-time job and and the better shift
and it would be perfectly reasonable for
on those four days when you're not
working to be on call with your local
fire department it's a win for everybody
you get an experienced person helping
out where they need it it doesn't
interfere with the job but and I'll look
to some of the members here who have
spent a career in firefighting
it seems to me that when you're on when
you have those three days on shift that
your fire chief should have some say
in whether you're going to be there on
time or whether you're going to leave
early or
whether there's an expectation that when
you're you've been on for 12 hours you
don't go and stay up the whole night
before you come back for another 12
hours and I reading between the lines
with the fire chiefs I would imagine
that there is a difference of opinion
that some people
are are willing to accommodate some
departments are willing to accommodate
more others less some of them probably
have very strict that on those three
days you're on shift you are here on
time and you stay for the whole shift
and in this case it's not a matter of
well you know they're out there saving a
life as a volunteer that's that's what
they're doing in their full-time job as
well
uh just on the last bill we talked about
Mr chairman you mentioned a number of
cases where we've left it to employers
to each figure out how to walk that line
and and there are different solutions
and I think
the employment environment is better for
that and to me that's this bill tries to
come up with one size fits all one way
to go
and I don't I believe that
the fire chiefs despite having a range
of opinions each one of those opinions
like my namesake said
I'm concerned that we were not there
with what the problem is what this
solution would do and whether we're
we're on the right path with it
okay gentlemen flip a coin
representative Cahill Boucher than I
would like to hear from some of the
professional firefighters thank you Mr
chair and I think the problem that we're
trying to address the reason the bill
came to us is because there is a problem
recruiting and retaining people for the
volunteer
but I'm not sure if this is the solution
to it because I what you know I talked
to my fire chief and and his biggest
challenge is that well
uh people that are living in town are
working 20 30 40 miles away so they're
not really able if they were willing to
come back and answer a call in our town
so I'm not sure I I'm just looking at
the municipal Association to try to find
out what the towns are doing to
incentivize or encourage and I guess
it's a mixed bag and we certainly we
don't want to mandate
anything but as far as help with the
training and and again if you're a
professional firefighter you you're
getting the training that you need to go
back and serve the community where you
reside which I think is is a win-win but
I don't know what there's something
about scheduling which you know you're
you're uh available to answer the call
and if you can't if you can't then you
don't
but you do have that compulsion to go
and save that life so it's I'm not sure
if this is something we can address in
labor
but again this gets back to having more
young people who can climb these ladders
and yet fit it into their work and life
schedule
thank you before you you thank you
original kale before you speak
representative Bouchard representative I
know you're itching to talk and hello
although this is a uh retained uh
session I'm going to let you speak in a
couple minutes I'd like everyone to have
their conversation if you would like us
because I know what it's like sitting
there when people are talking about a
bill you want so we're going to be a
little flexible here but I'm gonna let
everyone say their piece for a little
bit first so I will recognize you all
right representative Bouchard thank you
Mr chairman and I'll keep it brief
I'm I'm looking uh
at the um the scenario that if you are a
business owner
and choose to
start your business in a community that
does not have a full-time Fire
Department
I think you need to accommodate
for your Volunteer Fire Department
volunteer
firefighters
and that's why I
I will support this bill
okay
representative Drago you wanted I know
you wanted to be on this committee I'm
going to let you speak if you have
something to to say
sure
as as the bill is ran now I it's hard to
support and I
I don't know if it's better to pile on
amendments to make the bill better or if
it's better to collectively get ideas
and then just create a new one but
I agree with what representative
Bouchard was saying that if you are in a
community that doesn't have it then yes
it's good to help out
I don't think we need to legislate and
force businesses to do that
um and like what representative seaworth
said it's a one-size-fits all and I
don't think it's going to fit everybody
with the way the bills are in because if
I'm in a town that pays for fire service
and I'm already paying my taxes but I
have an employee that lives in the next
town over that doesn't
why am I paying taxes and also losing an
employee at the same time so that's just
an example of how it doesn't it doesn't
fit every situation I do agree there's a
recruiting issue
um
but I don't think forcing businesses
uh to lose employees
to staff a fire agency is a way to do it
or any emergency responder for that
matter
um
because there's two ways to do it one
you either pay taxes and the town hires
employees which we all know is not
feasible in some of these small towns
but at the same time a small business
who has two employees shouldn't have to
lose a day's wage of one of their one of
their employees who's now not providing
for his family but also the business
owner may not be making enough money off
the day for you know to keep his doors
open or whatever the situation is so
um I do have ideas on how to fix it but
I don't I don't know if that's the oh
God all right well a few things so I was
hoping representative Pratt was going to
be here representative Cahill and I
talked to him after the last meeting
after last house session and he was a
fire chief for 29 years and a few of his
ideas were
in the bill it could only be that if if
you work for a private company you're
only allowed to respond to structure
fires that will narrow down how often
the employee needs to be gone
um rather than you know maybe not for
the car accident so so forth but just
for the big emergencies
an idea I had is we need to incentivize
businesses if they're going to give up
an employee for the day
why as a town maybe not Vehicle
registrations or some something saying
hey you know you're getting half price
vehicle registration or
it shouldn't be only the business paying
or suffering not suffering but they
shouldn't be the only one that has a
skin in the game to staff a Town's fire
agency it should be the you know maybe
this is a town saving the money on the
payroll but maybe a portion of the I
don't know property tax or something to
some sort of discount some sort of
business tax something
that's kicked back
um there also needs to be some sort of
minimum employee amount
an employee that a company that only has
two employees is a lot different I think
I said this in the hearing it's a lot
different than a company that has 100
employees
um you know a Walmart can probably lose
the cashier for a few hours whereas if
you're an employer that has two
employees and you need both of them to
lift something heavy well now you're
standing around waiting for the guy to
show up so
um I was thinking a minimum amount of 10
employees this is only for 10 or more
employees
um
and then maybe do it that
a business only required if they have 10
employees one of them could be a
volunteer firefighter if it's 20
employees maybe two volunteers so it's a
tiered system so they're not losing a
bunch of their Workforce and it's based
off how many employees are in the
company so
um based on that I have a question for
you because I was thinking uh a little
differently
um I don't care so much of a building
burns down I care about the child who's
choking the person who's having a heart
attack the people trapped in a car in a
car accident that getting to those
things quicker
versus
um
you know is everyone it's always that
thing where as long as people are out of
the building type of thing then well
surround the building and don't let it
go anywhere you know the building could
be rebuilt but so I was I'm surprised
you're from a structure fire and there's
I'm more concerned with the the
emergency medical situation and I'm
certainly not a professional at this I
own a landscape business but
I that would probably be a question for
some of the people who have done this
before it sounded like the structure
fire is where they need more Personnel
whereas
going responding to a choking or
something like that there's usually
somebody that can do that it's more of
the uh all hands on deck situations that
they need the volunteers to be at so I
but I don't know that would be a
question for people who actually do this
well I would like I'm not I don't want
to put either either of you two
gentlemen on the spot but you are the
professionals you've had plenty of
experience so
um if you would rather opine I would
I would just say and I think Michael
agree with me
ever been retired seven years in the
fire service in the seven years has
changed drastically I served 29 years
Mark's been you know in Manchester for a
long time retired
okay
and I think the recruitment process
um there's a lot that goes into it
recruitment retention
um
in full-time
um firefighting so I believe there
probably is a problem
um getting volunteers matter of fact I
had a conversation with my wife's uncle
on this very subject because I think
that we had a bill when Brodie deshays
put in the bill
um there was an issue up in the rumney
area Wentworth area where they aren't
getting people responding the calls so
they asked if there was something they
could do and I said there'll probably be
a bill coming forth
um
but I think there's a delicate balance
here and how we do that you know it's
you know people when they're employed
um
again there's a fine balance as to you
know
do you hold the employers accountable
for not allowing these people to go I
don't believe that you know you can
really do that I mean they have a
business to run and I understand the
whole thing how we fix this problem
I don't know because it appears that
there's less and less people that are
interested in the fire service and in a
full-time position never mind
volunteering I mean I can tell you that
when I'm looking at the I have good
friends down in Ash still and I look at
the roster and from seven years ago
there's probably a hundred people that
have retired since I've been gone and so
there you know it seems like every year
they're putting on
um
they're putting on new people they just
had a um they hired 12 new people
but the list that they use
it appears they're getting smaller and
smaller so there are people that are
losing interest in these positions for
whatever reason it is so if they're
having problems in the full-time
positions
I understand there's a problem with
recruiting people to volunteer you know
on call some of those people get paid
volunteers are just doing it because it
may be a hobby to them so
is it a big problem I don't know how big
a problem it is I don't know what the
answer is but I think we definitely need
to have you know there's got to be a
delicate balance there somewhere along
well I've I've participated over the
years in less than five prevention for a
while over studies about how they rate
insurance
and part of the way they rate insurance
is they figure what is capacity what
kind of what can you deliver to the
scene how far are the trucks away from
the location uh how many firefighters
you have and and all that's an
assessment that's done and all that is
boiled down and becomes a rate
um so so there these assessments are
taking place and and and I'm sure at Tom
meetings
they're having the same discussion it's
all about risk it's all about how much
risk you want to take
um that you could hire
uh EMS people put them on full time
you could hire firefighters and put them
all on full time but when you don't
when you don't make that commitment then
you are assuming a certain amount of
risk
now everybody thinks that risk is
assigned to somebody else and so it's
your house all right so it's your family
that's in in big trouble and then they
think you know something we probably
should have kicked the tax rate up a
little bit brought somebody on full time
so in these towns where they're doing
this
um and there are many times
you know that are making this decision
and to bring a firefighter on today it's
not the 75 000. you know that's about
what you're north of that uh in
Manchester it's even higher uh EMS
people are probably in the 50 range so
it's expensive to do that
so the the the patchwork that we have of
trying to fill those holes and minimize
some of the risks is this such this
volunteer fire department environment
um it's not ideal and the more
complicated the service gets the more uh
the more emergency medical stuff that
comes on the busy of these communities
gets the higher the population rates get
the more pressure that puts on the
volunteer system and the more we the
more of an ass there is for uh for
businesses in these various communities
so I think um
you know I think we could we could do
this we could say
you know firefighters should should have
the right to get out but this is going
to come to a head at some point
and and firefighters are going to
communities are going to you know
businesses are going to start pushing
back saying look we should not have to
assume all this responsibility that it
should be somebody spread around the
community for this uh otherwise maybe
we'll think about going some somewhere
else and let me say to my colleague
who's uh you know when India who owns a
business and runs a business and the
idea that half of his crew could
potentially leave
um and go submit that's a big deal that
small a lot of small Employers in this
community that will just shut the
business down so it's um it's a very
tough call right now
let's break down the bills to what it
says here okay
no employer shall discharge or take any
other disciplinary action against any
employee by reason of failure of such
employee to report to work
at the commencement of such employees
regular working hours
where the failure is due to the
employees responding to an emergency in
his or her capacity as a volunteer
member of a fire department or ambulance
department
so what we're saying is the bill is
about
disciplinary action and discharge
okay
so
with the point of if people aren't it
doesn't say that I have to let them go
halfway through the day if there's a
fire call okay that's that's up to the
employer employee to discuss decide now
right now
such employee to show up for work at the
commencement of their period that's what
the bill says so narrow it down to what
it it is trying to do
the
um
discussion
bone of contention
between representative attitude and I
was the the the concept of discharge or
disciplinary action
my initial thought was okay you can't
discharge
but
where do we have that
fire
discharge versus disciplinary action
does the employer have some ability to
have some disciplinary action because
you don't want someone milking the thing
okay uh yeah every morning I don't feel
like going to work so if there's a call
I'm going to go and and when does it
become abuse so that's all we're trying
to do is narrow this so I think we all
agree that something probably should be
done and no one wants to be the one
whose neighbor friend family or whatever
um can't get the services they need
because they were in a volunteer
firefighters
no employer shall discharge or take any
disciplinary action against
I am in favor of not discharging
I have a little adjective over any kind
of discipline because I do still think
the employer needs to do something
representative attitude was like yeah
well but
three or four disciplines can equal a
discharge and my point was no you can't
discharge period end of story even if
you've got 20 disciplines you can't
discharge
so I would like to work on that aspect
of this to try to see if we can come up
with something without getting really
you know big in telling employers and
towns and everyone what to do
hit that and just decide between the
discharge and the disciplinary and try
to figure that out I will give you a
second but I saw a representative
Granger first Sullivan and andrego as I
saw the hands go ahead representative
Granger I think this is just a question
um wouldn't it be might it be better
just to make enabling legislation to
allow municipalities to decide how to
handle this on their own instead of us
saying that we have to make it Statewide
level rule that has to apply everybody
in coax County as well as National and
Manchester like it seems to me as though
if if we let the municipality sort of
figure it out then they would probably
figure out a much better system than
whatever we can come up with but this
isn't for municipalities this is
employer employee relationship
so we can't have a municipality told
employee employer relationship what it
should be
represent well that okay but if you want
Brian a second
um I just want to be able to look at
representative sorry
um
um so that's that's my thought of where
you're going do you
still agree or disagree go ahead just
have this so can towns not make any
rules for businesses and
boy that would be a stretch okay
I think Beyond zoning
uh planning board things and and stuff
like that I don't think any municipality
has any kind of authority to have any
kind of rule over employee employee
relationship
representative Sullivan followed by
Drago I I absolutely hear what you're
saying about uh someone who's uh
stretching the limits
um and why you might want to take the
discipline um
piece out of it however if
discipline can never lead to discharge
what's the point
I mean it
and then my other concern is if you've
got 25
if you've got 25 disciplinary letters
based on firefighting and then you're
late to work one day
um can you discharge for being late to
work with the record of 25 disciplinary
letters
I will let some other people speak and
I'll respond to that I just don't want
to give but and I think I have
legitimate response to that but go ahead
okay and it also say but if uh
representative wolf has uh some
Enlightenment to offer I'd love to hear
it yeah I want to I'm going to let
representative speak as the people and
then uh in love but uh represent if you
want to get ready uh wolf representative
wolf if you want to get ready to speak
in a few moments feel so I'm just going
to grab the people that are have their
hands up and then we'll let you say
something uh representative well I
should have raised my hand before
representative Sullivan because he was
like what happened over there same same
concept but I was thinking the same
thing well first off I do understand
that if it's during the day you can tell
the employee no you can't go we're busy
I have nothing to do with it I know I
know what you're saying okay
what if it's at 4am this is my question
what if it's at 4am
their shift starts at six do they call
their boss and say hey can I go so they
have to call no okay so what now but if
they're late you just can't fire them so
we can't fire the bill you can't fire or
right discharge or discipline okay so
that's where that's where I'm getting to
so now
my business we have a five-strike policy
um basically you know first offense
second Offense for being late well after
the fifth offense or the 25th offense
what's good to have a strike policy if
there's no consequence at the end so
what if you can't discharge an employee
for being late over and over and over
again but what's the incentive for them
to ever show up on time in the first
place so I I don't know our consequence
for the strike policy is you're
terminated but if you take that away but
what else can I do
um
the way I will respond to both
representative Sullivan and you on this
is
you cannot
fire them or discipline them the way the
bill says now for not showing up however
you must you know provide evidence if
that's where you were and
um
shall require you are not required to
compensate them
and you must provide from the chief
evidence of that's what you were doing
now I do think there are other reasons
if someone is late first of all
you have to look at the people that are
firefighters okay
they're a very special ilk of people all
right and they do something that most of
us wouldn't do
I don't see them as overall milkers of
any kind of situation I mean I'm going
to sit there and not work in my my desk
today so I can run into a burning
building and get hot and sweaty maybe
get burned and killed and to try to save
someone's life I mean so first of all I
don't see them as much as the milk or
secondly
what is the reason for the discipline
and not discharge well let's say
um
someone
I don't want to discharge them
but
I still can discipline someone for other
things okay you didn't do your job well
kind of a phrase trying to kind of lost
my train of thought here's where I'm
going
you're you're kind of what you're saying
and what we were saying representative
Sullivan says well if you can't
uh discharge them to what good is a
discipline or if there's so many
disciplines I think there's I don't
think you should discipline someone
for being late or going to a fire
you can discipline them for all other
reasons
and possibly fire them for discipline
for other reasons failure to do your job
and other things but I'm not sure that
that
putting the two together that that's my
problem you I think you're trying to put
them both together and I'm trying to
delineate them
yeah sure it's one of this conversation
you just said you can't you shouldn't be
able to discipline someone for being
late because they're at a fire
that's what the bill says you shouldn't
discipline them for being late because
they're out of fire
um at what point would you discipline
someone because of their being late
because they're out of fire because what
you're saying is take discipline out but
I I can't see why you need to take
discipline out
because you have to have that ability
I'm sorry to say that I feel the
employer needs to have the ability
if they feel it is being abused I don't
think those people are the type of
people that abuse things but I still
think if someone is abusing them there
needs to be some mechanism should
someone be doing that that's the only
reason I I'm wary about putting that in
but it doesn't say only in cases of
abuse basically if the employer isn't it
is annoyed because there there's been
five fires in the last two weeks
um they could discipline because they're
annoyed not because there's abuse
so that's redefine after the word
discharge or take any disciplinary let's
redefine what you want to do there so
you and I both get what we want with a
couple different sentences
representative uh uh Drago person and uh
yeah I was basically going to say the
same thing again it's I'm not saying
anybody I'm not saying they're going to
go fight a fire and then run to Duncans
and say you know what I just I'm gonna
kill another hour I I don't think that's
the case I think it's responsible people
who are going to get back to the job as
quickly as possible what I'm saying is
if I have a job that needs to be done by
Friday I stand to lose money if it
doesn't get done and there happens to be
three emergencies that that week in the
morning
well now I'm getting a little frustrated
that my employee is going even if he
comes in right after the fire or
whatever the emergency is I still lost
time that morning which is slowing my
job down
and I should have the ability as an
employer to say
this situation isn't working
maybe they don't get fired right away
agreed which is why one of my amendments
was
if you show up late but if you're if but
if you're you're this does not say
in which we can add in it does not say
that your employer can tell you when you
cannot
if you have a situation where you have a
bunch of perishable stuff it has to be
planted that day right okay or you're
working for I.T and you're turning the
whole company over that day
okay
you can't
be late that day
you can't go to the fire that morning
because of that it does not say that the
employer can't tell you on certain times
no you can't do that you're not gonna
well then that's tomorrow that was a
question I had asked because if it's 4
a.m and they get a call
is there a call to the boss saying hey
what's going on for today's schedule is
it okay if I take this or are they just
automatically showing up late and that's
what needs to be differentiated there
there needs to be a give and take
amongst the employer and the employee
and plus the town because if I'm just
finding out at 6 30 in the morning that
my employee is not going to be in for
the day or not the day for the next two
hours without a phone call first to say
hey can I take this can I go then that's
the problem and then if I don't have
disciplinary measures to take after that
what you just tied my hands completely
again that's why I'm trying to narrow it
down between discharge discipline and
then what the employer can do by
agreeing it or not agreeing to it
depending on certain and what it and
what if they try it for five months say
say I have an employee tomorrow that
does this and we try for five months and
I say this isn't really this this
doesn't work I I didn't know beforehand
now I know
now what do I do it doesn't say anything
in the bill it says you know it's it's
silent so again if you want to add a few
sentences to something that says however
say no to the you can't take the calls
anymore yeah
and that but I still can't get rid of
them so if they
I guess my question is if you can't if
you can't ever part ways because
the employee can just tell them they
can't go on certain
well again
this is what we're getting down the road
but I'm going to pull over to wolfen but
Granger has a Santa
we're we're getting down to the real
things
as to what the employer can do if you're
going to put something in place
mandating an employer can't discipline
or discharge you should be able to put
other things in there that give the
employer the ability to say when they
can or when they can
so I could just say well we don't work
weekends so you can just do it on the
weekends possibly well then I would be
okay with that that would mean again
yeah this is a big thing right we're
trying to bring down
small because it's hard without having
it's hard to do this without saying the
ultimate thing is we part ways Because
unless
it just as a business owner it's very
hard to understand a situation where
I can't say no this just isn't working
wait this is you could basically say
that for anything but I could go to any
one of my employees tomorrow and say you
know what I own the business this just
isn't working
work out far aways but now we're writing
a bill that says I can't do that for
this specific situation that's very
tough and I'm not the one to say I'll
just come up with some other reasons to
get rid of them I'm going to be honest
and say this is the reason I'm not going
to say well I just don't like your job
performance for the afternoons you're
slow or whatever no I'm not going to do
that if this is the reason that's what
I'm going to say I'm not going to skirt
the issue by saying this is the reason I
it's just very hard to figure out a way
that it makes sense as an employer
that I can't I
am a better word I'm stuck with the
employee but no other positions like
that I don't understand why this bill
would do the same thing that's why
you're paying the big bucks to make
these tough decisions Ranger Then
followed by representative wolf is it
okay Mike if I have representative we'll
come up after
representative Granger and then
representative wool so thinking about
everything you just said there's uh one
real obvious thing to do as an employer
to sort of sidestep this whole issue and
never deal with it and that's just never
hire a fireman and that seems to be an
obvious solution that we don't want to
encourage uh it doesn't seem to be so
the if the goal of the legislation is to
get people to volunteer for fire service
and you're putting them in a situation
where they can you know they can go
through the map and realize well if if
any potential employer down the road
knows that I'm a fireman and they they
can't fire me or whatever and they
they're they're gonna be the the
potential volunteer firemen is going to
be able to figure out well why would I
volunteer for this then
um I could you know just not have a job
entirely and you know
so
you at the beginning when you first hire
someone who's a fireman let's say all
right and they go on on several calls
and you can discipline them but never
you know fire them or never you know
actually end the contract then you'll
have learned a very valuable lesson and
um you'll have learned it in the hard
way you'll you'll have learned don't
fire a fireman and all the other
businesses so there's probably going to
be a year or two right at the beginning
after if this passes as it is where
people are actually joining up to be
volunteer firefighters but then you know
people will figure out pretty quick that
it doesn't actually work out so if if
the goal is to increase the number of
volunteer firemens there seems to be a
much broader variety of ways to do that
that don't have perverse incentives in
there
valid point representative wolf you've
heard a lot of conversation
feel free to step up to the microphone
and and uh tell us where we're right
thank you Mr chairman committee members
um this bill has certainly taken on a
life
much bigger than I thought it was when
going to be when I proposed
the original Bill to OLS
I've had two firemen volunteers come to
me and say
I'm being beaten on by my boss because
I've had a couple of incidents
not big not many but a couple of
incidents where I was late
and they were reprimanded for showing up
late
and they now are in a position
where they have to make a decision
do I continue on to work or do I
attend to that accident that I just
drove by
I think what we were talking about here
is and I don't know very many
firefighters that are going to try to
make a mathematical decision as to
whether I get more money as a
firefighter or as a volunteer where I
don't get any you know we have some call
Firefighters Etc
I would like the intent of this bill was
that if a firefighter is responding is
going to work and ends up responding on
the way to work
not leaving in the middle of the day or
any of that sort of stuff that they
cannot be reprimanded or fired for
performing their duties as
as they're on their way to work that was
all the intent of the bill was
and I'm happy to answer questions I
think it's just grown beyond that all
right representative just a second guys
section
RSA 153 a17
okay is a current law if I can read two
sentences for you okay
no license emergency medical care
provider who in good faith attempts to
render Emergency Medical Service
authorized by this chapter at an
emergency scene while enroute to a place
of employment they'll receive any form
of reprimander penalty by employer as a
result of later arrival of the place of
employment
that is current law when it comes to
EMTs
I am 100 willing to give the same thing
to Firefighters if on their way to work
they come across something in render
service
any comments getting a call on the way
I'll read it it's 153 a 17.
this came to me because representative
wolf said well the the EMTs already have
it so I went to look at it
so I pulled this up and it it wasn't as
much as is
it's really not the so I was confused
because the bill in hand in front of us
isn't really consistent with this but I
was always okay with it so let me read
it one more time no license emergency
medical provider who is in good faith
attempts to render emerging medical
service authorized by this chapter at an
emergency scene while enroute to a place
of employment
shall receive any form of reprimanded
penalty by an employer result of late
arrival so if they come across a fire
they come across a traffic accident and
you are a firefighter an EMT or you are
driving to work and you see a house on
fire you go in you grab people you pull
them out you start putting the hose on
and do whatever on the way to work it
doesn't say about oh I hear a call the
if you want to extend this exact
sentence
president Cahill you can either address
me or or was it a wolf uh Mr chair when
did you just spread you just said uh on
the way to work for responding
is that what you is that what I heard
you say responding to a call in route to
a place of employment responding
emergency medical provider who is in
good faith attempts to render Emergency
Medical Service authorized by this
chapter at an emergency scene
while enroute to a place of employment
shall receive no discipline so you could
make it say any firefighter but
um in good faith attempts to render
firefighting services or medical
services
authorized by their whatever
at an emergency scene while enroute to
the employment
but it doesn't really say that you know
if they get a call on their on their
pager it doesn't say that but it doesn't
it doesn't say it's not either no but I
think correct I mean but it's a lot
yeah I mean I like it it's not perfect
but it's a lot better than it was yeah I
like it but I you know because it could
be something to interpretation I think
it would be or you can add you if you
come across it but you can't like
deviate from your route to go to a call
I mean well we can we can amend a
sentence yeah representative wolf I I
think as you and I have spoken
that takes care of 95 percent of
situation you put the firefighters in
with the EMS people fine the situation
that you just mentioned representative
your pager goes off
on your belt as you're going to the
front as you're going to work
in the buyer or the call is just on the
next street over
and they should be able to go
so language in there
responding to
on the way to work
and that's what I would make it whether
they come across it or they're getting a
pager to go to it
I may make it more narrow but I think uh
I'm gonna okay that's all we were
looking for so they can't be disciplined
they can't be discharged because they're
going and so it's not leading from work
it's not it's not leaving for work right
okay or anything like that
representative colcom love either to me
or the uh representative thank you and I
know I'm splitting hairs here and being
very specific on this but what about
when they're returning to work from
lunch midday
no no no
they've already signed in I mean let's I
mean we can sit here and go through all
of the what-ifs
but if you get that it shows
that the communities
believe in their firefighters and want
to have them and not be so represent so
if the call goes off at four o'clock in
the morning
okay and they are going to work at six
well they got to be there at six okay uh
it's a it's it's when they're in you
know in route from their residence to
well that's the way that's the way the
current law is
with emergency that they come across it
okay now the question is
um if it's in the pager that's next
street over
maybe we have to add a sentence that
said either yay or nay okay
um but um I think we're all going at
least a little better I I have to pull
them as I saw them representative love
Brian one and Brian too
uh
I think I think we're not addressing the
the you know representative Drago's um
original thing the the financial burden
here you know the financial burden on
the employer
okay and the municipality kind of
skating because they just have this
you know volunteer thing and um you know
it's not as a you know we heard seventy
five thousand dollars for for a a
full-time firefighter
um
could we amend it to say that um you
know that the the city Town municipality
whatever uh can because we can't shall
anything
um you know uh without without funding
it
um
can
um you know negotiate a a fair and
decent uh you know Financial
um
help for the for the employer uh you
know it's the employer can prove he lost
uh you know 500 or whatever that day
um
you know I'm gonna you know it's I
couldn't support that a representative
love I understand where you're coming
from
you know we have a there's a if you guys
have ever noticed anything on your
homeowner's insurance policy there's a
little liability there so if you come
into a car accident
and you're in in a car accident happens
and and
um
while you're
um uh trying to pull this person out of
a burning car which happened on 93 this
week uh you break their arm or while you
give CPR to them you crack a couple ribs
there's a little thing in your liability
in your insurance policy for giving
Medical Aid
okay and just for the for those reasons
um
I still believe in this whole thing of
helping my fellow man and I would think
someone would want to stop on a way if
they see a house on fire or a car
accident and give and give Aid and and
uh I'll forego the the loss of the
employer on that one because I think
I'm more in favor of letting people help
their fellow man for the the because
it's the right thing to do
so but I I hear what you're saying well
I I was just saying you know if
representative Drago has a dozen guys
working for him and if two of them uh
two or three times a month
or going to calls
um we're not going to calls
representative love this is on the way
to work
coming across or seeing so isn't that
what the original bill was about no no
it's it's no as representative wolf said
it kind of got blown up as to leaving
work okay doing all these other things
into others so uh representative
Sullivan uh damn it
representative seaworth and Sullivan
yeah it might help might help
um so I wanted to say I have to agree
with representative Holcomb's
interpretation of the existing law when
I see
um the phrase while on route to a place
of employment
I don't see anything about where you've
started on that route why or when a
couple of jobs ago I routinely had to
move between places of employment during
the day
and I would think that if I were
traveling
an hour up north
to get to my second place I needed to be
that day
um that I would be on route to that
place of employment and I kind of hope
that if I saw somebody on the side of
the road that needed emergency medical
attention and I was an EMT I could
pull over and help them and be protected
by this law so I I don't think
and I I
this is not an argument against
expanding this law I think
I I actually like that idea
um but I don't read this as being as
narrow as it was suggested that it's
only before you've made it to your first
time card punch of the day
um to me
this could be any traveling between jobs
for
well I'm glad you and representative
colcum brought that up so with the power
invested in me as chairman of this
committee I will have um you and
representative caulkham come up with an
amendment to 153 a17 outlining that for
firefighters and present it to the
committee before our next meeting
Representatives
I happen to believe a simple is good
um I like the direction it's going the
one
one piece of confusion I've got is where
it says under this chapter and I'm
concerned that firefighters might not
fit under that chapter
um so
um I support the idea of doing an
amendment check into that aspect of it
it
I'm not sure how you solve it OLS can
solve anything
so um just so you know what very valid
point representative Sullivan
153 a emergency medical and Trauma
Services is the chapter under Public
Safety and Welfare so you are correct we
may very well be able to take
153 a17
2 and place it
an identical section maybe under
something I don't know is there a place
that where it belongs is there RSA for
uh you know any it's probably this one
it's not because this is 275 okay which
is the the work which is basically the
labor law
so
um OLS maybe may be able to find the
right spot a little bit of a more
meeting in the minds of what we want to
do here with this
represent a wolf any last comment uh I
was just going to say real quick and
I believe that
people that are certified as a first
responder EMT firefighter
um
because I I'm pretty sure that this was
drilled into me when I was in the fire
service that if you're coming across
something
regardless of when it is
um and I think people are covered under
Good Samaritan law that aren't but I
think you have an obligation
to stop and assist if you come by an
accident I mean if somebody saw my truck
driving away with a union sticker on the
back I'm sure people are not going to be
happy if I just go I'm not stopping for
this accident and it happened to me one
morning when I was actually going to
work
in Nashua heading down the road to go to
work and all of a sudden I see smoke
coming from a building
stop my truck now it's 7 30 I have to re
I have to respond to work at eight
o'clock now I'm the first one there day
before the fire trucks ran inside the
building got the people out of the
building wasn't late for work thankfully
but I think there is something and maybe
I'm mistaken but if we could find that
out there may be an obligation for
people to have to
um stop
and render assistance
this is the only thing that was brought
to my attention I guess I can have OLS
do some research or our researcher try
to figure out if there is one similar
but your point being let's say
um you lived in Amherst in your
Brookline and you're on the way to
you're living it in this case you were
in living in Nashville you were going to
your job in Nashville let's say you were
crossing two towns and you stopped in an
adjoined town where you didn't work
and then and then you got to work an
hour late
I don't want you to be disciplined we're
not doing for for doing that
obviously when the other guys show up
you can then go on your way or whatever
that's much more consistent with this
final hands representative wolf
I guess uh
uh Mr chairman sir I think if we can
narrow it down to something simple like
that we don't have
to my knowledge firemen that are out
milking the system the communities are
not trying to save a few bucks by having
volunteers do it versus
uh full-time firemen
we're trying to improve the recruitment
of these volunteers and someday we'll
all have full-time fire departments
but in the meantime we need to get these
people we need to have them want to come
to work
and not be fearful of being reprimanded
or losing their job and I think your
solution is I agree my uh favorite uncle
was a fire volunteer firefighter for 20
some years he worked at Hamilton
standard by Bradley Airfield over in
Hartford and he responded to the tornado
they had there and the fire in the hotel
and all the other stuff so I I have a an
allegiance to my to my favorite uncle
and his volunteer and the stuff that he
did over the years I probably could
never do so I agree with you thank you
representative
representative Sullivan just procedural
if there is an amendment that's put
together if it could be circulated
before we have an executive session that
way if there's if all of us nitpicky
people find something that uh uh is uh
is a problem we won't have to deal with
it uh on the day of the executive
session uh very valid point I will make
sure that it's not even the day before
or two days before that everyone should
have it for at least a week so that's
why representative kulkum and seaworth
and I will make sure you get that to you
if you indulge me a little
light-heartedness can I put and they
cannot refuse to hire them in this
amendment too
no
all right very well folks go have lunch
one o'clock is
um OSHA
any other comments anyone need anything
thank you appreciate everyone's
today
in the calendar which is sort of like if
you see a better price than they charge
you you can get it at a lower price they
did it does say
work session for the whole committee so
I understand this subcommittee is
okay
um I if I'm not mistaken I think the uh
the chairman asked me to lead this one
up since he's not here I'm going to do
um but um I think this is going to be
sort of an organizational meeting and I
think there's going to be several more
coming
um uh come September
um the speaker has yet again uh shut
down the state house for the months of
July and August and this time I
understand that this is not a committee
that can meet during July and August
um so um
so
um
where we start
but the purpose for retaining one of the
reasons was just to let people who are
interested in um uh speaking up and
getting their perspectives across good
give them a chance because frankly when
we had the study committee it started
quite late we ended up getting a
sidelined for two critical months of
July and August and
um we ended up having to conclude
without hearing from the various groups
that might be affected by this again
it's public sector OSHA so essentially
it's going to take the OSHA safety
um
standards section 1910
to and and which applies to all private
sector workers in the state
and apply it to the public sector
workers
it does not invite OSHA into
New Hampshire it just invites their
standards so it will still be the
Department of Labor that does the
inspections
works with public sector employees the
way they always have
and but they'll simply have a more
up-to-date set of Standards I think in
earlier conversations
um with the Deputy Commissioner
um I think we've acknowledged that it's
been over 10 years since the Department
of Labor safety standards have been
reviewed and upgraded
um so it's clear that that's something
that's not working right now and rather
than
um
engage in an effort to upgrade all those
we can simply take the private sector
OSHA standards and apply them to the
public sector and when they get upgraded
the private public sector standards for
New Hampshire will automatically get
upgraded
um
so
the groups that I'm anticipating hearing
from I know commissioner erlinghaus is I
think in finances he's
no my physical committee yeah that's
right that's a Friday thing
um so he will he will try to drop in uh
as he has a chance but the department of
administrative surfaces definitely has
an interest I know the county is is
expressed interest in
this issue I would anticipate that the
um Municipal Association would also be
interested as might the schools the fire
and police
um
um are there other groups that I'm
and that's National
um so I I don't know a few gentlemen are
here to provide input or just to listen
but if you're interested in input and
I'm not quite sure which organization
I'm David Ross from Hillsborough County
I'm representing the nursing homes for
the the County Association
um we were definitely would like to be
participative in this process
um the incorporation of these standards
into the health care sector will be
meaningful and impactful for us some
things that we really would want to
consider
um is the opportunity for us to be able
to articulate really what some of the
specific impacts would be we have to go
through those a little bit more in
detail to be able to give you that I'm
not prepared to give you that detail
today
but also the timeline for implementation
in the bill as it was proposed the
implementation date was going to be 60
days from from passage and incorporating
that timeline certainly wouldn't be
feasible for us with any meaningful
possibility so we'd like to be engaged
in this discussion if that's okay and I
know that the effective date has been a
subject of
in-depth discussion and I don't think 60
days was uh likely to be a part of that
that consideration I I think we were
looking at it substantially later uh
implementation date
um and there's uh
just some questions to um you know
exactly what the best mark would be
um so we welcome having you here and
have you received a copy of the uh the
file that the Department of Labor has
put together with the side by side for
1910. we do have that yes yep so we're
currently going through that now to be
able to take a look at that and see if
we can identify from a facilities
perspective what those impacts would be
and then what the cost implications may
be as well okay that's great thank you
thank you
does anybody else have questions or
so the tell me what you're using now
because a private nursing homes or in
the ocean
and there's a separate standard as I
understand for uh for nursing homes
so tell me what what are you currently
following are you following the the uh
stuff from Rudy and from a DOL or you
have accessing a national statement yeah
so we follow a combination of Standards
so we follow
um certainly the department of labor
standards that are in existence and also
standards that are established by the
center for Medicare Medicaid services
CMS we have to follow CDC guidelines
they incorporate references to National
standards as well we have to follow
emergency preparedness standards which
impact um you know life safety
compliance with life safety codes
but the OSHA standards that are
referenced here
incorporate very specific and targeted
changes that are not consistent with
current policies and procedures within
our facilities
the private sector you're absolutely
right does something very different so
they've Incorporated those from the
get-go so our organizations have really
been established on a different
foundation so we have to really create a
different structure to be able to ensure
compliance
follow-up so the uh the standards that
you referred to do you have any sense
that they
um they're more specific to your reading
stream
um do you have any sense of how they
when you put them side by side I mean is
there should we carve out for instance
or just reference you know the the
standards you were referring to now
would that does that cover the ground
does it
more specific to our industry as opposed
to something like this we would
certainly appreciate that
um I think that that would certainly
make it very specific
um and helpful for us because it
wouldn't require some substantial change
for us the OSHA standards reference on
very specific implementation standards
um and things that reference
specifically targeted education that
encompers
um very specific topics
um referencing specific signage within
facilities different policies and
procedures that are not specifically
referenced in our existing policies or
in the Life Safety Code so we would have
to go back and you know Implement those
things not that it's a bad thing it's
thank you
thank you Mr Ross
Rudy and I have had a couple of
conversations
um
one of which I thoroughly confused him
um and I think
earlier today maybe I uh did away with
confusion I was I and might go into this
again when commissioner erlinghaus comes
up if if he makes it but I was talking
with some weeks ago
Joyce Pittman who is also with the
dominant Department of administrative
Services
um approached me saying that um
you know they're responsible for all of
the Departments and agencies in the
state and she was concerned that they
might need some help with figuring out
exactly what
um
what they need to do to make adjustments
and
um we're looking for some consultant
assistants and um
the
when I was talking to Rudy he thought I
was referring to a consultancy program
which is part of the state plan which
we're not doing so basically
what I am hoping
um and I think Miss Pippin who's hoping
is that the department might be able to
um
you know if we get this passed the
department might be able to assist some
of the uh public sector groups with some
consultant
assistance with making that transition I
don't know if you can speak to that Rudy
um thank you so yeah I was confused no
it was my fault not yours
um
we would have to just look in terms of
the level of effort of that so we would
certainly always look to assist any
employer if they're saying hey I have
compliance questions
um that's presently what we do on a
one-off type of capacity is like when we
go in and perform an inspection if they
say here are our issues here are
concerns we work with them now if
they're talking about a uh kind of a
across the state type level of effort it
would take a long time to do all
agencies we could certainly handle you
know like an agency comes to us and says
here's our operation here's what we're
doing slash not doing
um so it's something to think about I
mean I guess I would be interested in
terms of when she's saying that is what
timeline is she thinking of is she
thinking of like again like a
prospective look at the 60 some odd
boards and agencies and say are they
good to go not good to go or is she
thinking like we
stagger that out in terms of you know go
through them at some type of pace but in
a general sense the consultancy or
working with employers on coming into
compliance is something we're
comfortable with providing training is
something we're comfortable with I guess
just in terms of what is the timeline or
expectation so that would be something
we would want to look at and be sorted
out right that might also play into
where we pick the implementation date
um
where would the department be at with
regard to
um
I mean I've said over and over again
that I've never considered our
department of labor to be a punitive
um entity
um you know got a gotcha type of entity
um so if um if uh public and some of the
public employers were still
learning and making transitions after
um after the implementation date how
would the department deal with that
probably similar to how we deal with
them now which is again to be clear we
go in and deal with employers now who
are not in compliance with existing
standard and the way that we deal with
them is those violations are cited that
there's an a period for remediation and
our civil penalties relative to safety
are incredibly low usually we held the
penalties uh civil penalties for safety
violations are held in abeyance allowing
the employer to go through a remediation
process
and I I think
some of the fear that we've
experienced with the study committee and
also the um uh
the earlier subcommittee I think is
based on a fear that the
that we're they're going to be facing
OSHA's um penalties which isn't true
because it's Department of Labor that's
going to be implementing this and I
think they're fearful that there's going
to be some gotcha activity going on and
I've never
never had that impression exactly what
you said is what we've always believed
is the case so people I mean essentially
a violation would be an opportunity to
uh to make an adjustment and learn
correct yep um
anyone else have questions along those
lines
thank you commissioner
so when I'm trying to get my arms around
is uh the scope of this the scope of the
uh
of this
trying to match these two
kind of Standards so you have the
current standard which I would assume is
a product of the DOL and the rules and
ranks and all that's what's been
developed over a period of time
and then we were hearing from others who
were saying well it's such a big
undertaking to comply to comply with the
OSHA standard and at some point we're
going to have to reconcile those things
there's going to have to be
um you know some some way of measuring
so where are you on the scale of things
so where is the you know this department
of the state on in terms of you know so
to me
we don't know what the scope of it so
it's easy and I was a lobbyist for a
long time because easier said it's going
to cost us all this money but you got to
quantify that and that's what I think is
going to be the challenge uh and quite
frankly I
we know what the standard is uh it's out
there
um and so if somebody comes into this
committee I hope that you can help them
and others can help them begin the
process of identifying
so where is the conflict where where are
the big areas that we are going to be
problematic as we move forward
and I don't know how big that is
I I think you have identified uh the as
this conversation has gone on one thing
that has continually come up is it is
difficult to quantify and certainly
qualify those costs
um what I have tried to say um
consistently is that there are
significant differences and mainly it's
the gentleman who spoke uh before me I
think spoke very well it's really a lack
of specificity uh our current standards
are very uh non-specific they are very
general uh something I have said in the
past is that does not mean that there
are no standards it just means that when
we run across we're typically working
backwards and what I mean by that is if
we go into an employer after there has
been a safety concern
we would look at it and say okay we
don't have a specific standard on what
occurred or what didn't occur but we
have a general duties clause and then
when we try and flesh out what the
general duty of care would be for that
employer we might look to OSHA we might
look to CDC we might look to all of
these different things and then that's
where we come forth with a
recommendation to that employer and say
hey going forward you had this event
going forward you should probably adhere
to these types of Standards under your
general duty Clause you've identified a
hazard
general duty would suggest you follow
these established standards but they're
not set forth specific in New Hampshire
state law so again I'm not just trying
to Ramble On and On I think you're
absolutely right that it is difficult to
say this is going to cost x amount more
it's difficult to say that this is going
to take this amount of time
um but there is a gap the Gap is we are
not very specific our standards a lot of
times we are referencing a general duty
clause and then the general duty Clause
we look elsewhere we look to OSHA we
look to CDC we look to best industry
what I'm trying to get at is do we have
to if there are standards that are
currently out there that have been
implemented
um they provide a certain level of
safety that are industry standards a
prison being one of them you know they
have the prisons have their own
standards in fact I think they're exempt
for motion they're not mistaken
so
can those be part of this
um
this scheme of developing a uh this
whole program of Osha and protections
for work and so
are do we have to we have to wipe the
Slate clean and then Begin Again in
building and building all this can I
it's a very different approach
um the um and Mark since you're new to
representative McKenzie since you're uh
new to this process
um back when we had the study committee
um the Department of Labor did a ton of
work on doing a side-by-side comparison
of the department of labor standards
and in the um uh not only in 1910 but
the other two sets of standards and we
concluded the 1910 would be the most
applicable one to uh public sector in
New Hampshire and um and so that's there
and every you know that should be a big
actually maybe you could just uh send
those out to all members of the labor
committee
yeah we'll sum that out yeah and and it
I'll warn you it's a very large file and
when you initially open it it opens up
completely to I don't remember how many
thousands of pages it is but it's it's
um it's it's big but once you save it to
your hard drive and then reopen it from
the hard drive
it opens up a table of contents with
little bullets and you can you can click
on one at a time you experience this did
you
it freaks you out to begin with but once
you do the save and reopen
um you you get a very workable document
that does a very nice job of comparison
comparing the the OSHA and the
department of labor standards so so
um that was one of the big pieces of
work that needed to be done
the Deputy Commissioner very
legitimately said that he embraced the
idea of doing it but needed to be told
he had to do it because it's a big job
and
um I'm witness to the fact that it was a
very large job go ahead without being
dismissive of those efforts the one
thing I want to be clear on and I do
Apollo you know to the gentleman behind
us and I would acknowledge this when
Miss Pittman had brought it up as well
to be clear it's not as in-depth or
granular as some people would probably
want it is showing you OSHA has this
section we have nothing OSHA has this
section this is what New Hampshire has
it does not qualify or say what the
differences might mean in terms of
operations or costs or anything like
that and I only point that out I do
think it's a useful document and I you
know we did it so I'm not trying to be
dismissive of it I just point out that
you know I think some folks want more
and I acknowledge that it is not it's
not like a you know some consultancy
prod you know it wasn't that it was put
together and it answers all questions
uh if that makes sense
but it does a very nice job of showing
where where we are in comparison and
sometimes it's just OSHA word words it
one way in Department of Labor words in
a different way and you've you've got to
sort of stare at it for a while see if
it's just uh equivalent or different
um but uh but it is a very helpful
document and uh very useful and
um
so you so with that and I haven't seen
it
um
do you at some point incorporate uh in
that process those standards which are
currently in place uh for various
Industries throughout the state
are the other counties whatever the case
may be so
where there's the OSHA standards is the
is the DOL uh stuff but there are also
standards that are currently safety and
health centers are currently in place to
a whole variety of public sector the
fire has it the prison Sabbath nursing
homes have it so uh you know so what I
don't want
there's no this there is a gap but I
don't know how big that Gap is you know
what I'm trying to say yeah absolutely
and to be clear this document does not
pull in those other standards this is
literally uh just the 1910 to 1400 or
277. it does not reference other
standards
and and I don't think we wanted to
because basically this bill
um adopts the 1910 OSHA standards no
others I don't think we want to
complicate it by I'm bringing all sorts
of other organizations and other
standards in
um the nursing homes may already be
subject to
um other safety standards through other
organizations that
um you know are watching them
um but this bill is simply adopting the
OSHA standards no others
I'm trying to think if there's anything
else before you take off on us um
I had hoped that we'd have more more
folks you know showing interest today if
it was in the calendar for two weeks but
um I haven't seen anything
representative Schultz this question May
um feel free to to say or help me
clarify if this is too broad of a
question
um I think it would be helpful to know
since there is already a process from
your
um from your department
to address those safety standards and
all these other areas of the states and
to what degree
I guess it would be hard to know exactly
all the specifics for the new
application of that but roughly say how
many staff folks do you have working on
these issues and do you currently hire
any contractors for trainings or
investigations like what sort of
infrastructure do you have covering
workplace safety for what our laws
already cover
and if that's too broad I'm open to the
correct way to ask that
no I I think I understand the question
so in terms of existing infrastructure
the department historically has had uh
three to three and a half folks covering
safety that's been made up of two
inspectors
um in administrative slash clerical
support staff and then a portion of the
director of inspections time in the last
either 18 months or 12 months I guess
I'd have to look look back and see
specifically higher dates we've hired
now another safety inspector so where we
had two we now have three full-time
safety inspectors we still have the
support staff
and a portion of the director of
inspections time
I would point out that we're presently
in the process regardless of what
happens with this prospective
legislation we are currently in the
process of taking uh one of our
positions and and turning that into a
safety uh manager the safety manager
position uh would manage directly the
field inspectors and that administrative
uh clerical support person and they
would then report uh to the director of
inspection and then up through the
commissioner so in terms of just
Staffing we're probably looking to at
we've added one full-time safety
inspector and we are looking to add one
other position and when I say add
specifically what we're doing is taking
a current vacant position and
follow-up okay that's very helpful
um along those same lines are there any
entities because I know for sure that
the private sector hires Consultants to
help them and there's a lovely place
here in in the north part of Concord
that hosts groups on a number of levels
about safety and that is I'm fairly
certain not a state I think those are
Consultants that work on that with
industries that need it do you hire
Consultants to help with any aspect of
this from PR developing
workplace safety Flyers like at any
level do you
um have any Consultants that assist with
this sort of safety work for the
I talked to you real quick earlier uh
under the workers comp reform in 1993
that was created a section of the law
that um
that created safety enhancement programs
and you mentioned that you that you use
this but it does seem to
authorize the commissioner of of Labor
to offer these programs safety
enhancement programs and to hire
Consultants to do some of this work it's
specific to that it looks like and and
Grant provide grants to uh as well so
that that's been around for a long time
and you might we mentioned you mentioned
a little bit how you use that so yeah
presently the and thank you for for
showing that and speaking to me about it
earlier there is within the workers comp
section 281a a particular provision
which speaks to the Department's uh
safety training uh what that has been
and uh utilized presently as is that our
safety inspectors will as part of our
training programs and Outreach that we
do for employers a certain portion of
those trainings are dedicated to a
safety inspector providing an overview
of an employer's requirements under 281
a64. now those are certainly more narrow
than what we're talking about uh today
under 281 a64 we're talking about safety
summary forms uh that's the requirement
that employers of 15 or more individuals
in the state provide a safety summary
form detailing you know I have a program
this is what my program entails
additionally our safety inspectors at
those uh
seminars presently are speaking to Joint
Loss Management committees again that's
a requirement under 281 a64 that
employers of 15 or more have an
operating joint Loss Management
committee which discusses safety issues
and makes recommendations relative to
safe operation of the employer in their
utilization of employees so again
representative McKenzie understand your
point was is that perhaps that could be
looked at with a broader view
presently what that's being utilized or
looked at for is under 281 a64 the
safety summary form and Joint Loss
Management program but it's something
that we can look at it would be helpful
if you could take a look and see if that
statute does apply to what
what we may want to do here in
transitioning from DOL standards to OSHA
standards um if it if it doesn't apply
we might want to come up with some
mirror language to attach to this bill
so that
um we can have the uh
the directive to the Department of Labor
and an appropriation if needed to um
to make that happen for the various uh
public sector uh Employers in and to be
clear on that provision right now there
are no grants or no Appropriations or
anything like that it literally is a
training uh where our safety inspectors
will provide that training so there's
presently no appropriation or grants
offered or anything of that nature so
probably we would need to create
something similar but uh applied
specifically to the um the safety
standards correct
depending upon what you wanted to do
with it
but that that statute doesn't do it no
okay
very good
anything else for the Deputy
Commissioner
commissioner erlinghaus uh do you have
some thoughts you might want to share
with the
committee
I don't I don't really
um I'm here and and I think somebody
probably told you that you know Joyce
Pittman would be here but she had a
scheduled long scheduled day off and the
last thing I do is ask valued employees
to cancel vacations it is summertime yes
exactly
um no I think you talked to Rudy and
Rudy's the expert and uh you know our
department is obviously able to
um from a state perspective help
Implement whatever policy decisions the
committee makes and all of that and I
think we recognize that uh Department of
administrative services will have uh
um a lot of ground to cover with regard
to all of the agencies and departments
so um we want to make sure that we're
setting you up for success I think to
the extent to you know depending a lot
on what you end up deciding to do I you
know we've talked in the past about
um there's a significant
um
there's a cost to it in doing the
evaluation of you know where the state
is what changes have to be made and all
of that so if you start looking at an
appropriation I would encourage you to
to take that into consideration it's not
you know a significant transition
depending on what you're doing is not
something that couldn't be done with
existing staff right
go ahead hi commissioner
this may be relevant or it may not
um my spouse worked at admin Services
before your tenure so I know some from
his point of view as it's been shared I
know that there are existing
um things that already address safety
just because it's the smart thing to do
from ergonomic training I don't know
what department that comes out of
um maybe eight the HR I forget what you
call HR in your admin services but uh
two of course if there is a state-run
facility that needs the Safe Serve
training for Food Service workers
because you have some food service
workers so there there must be already
just for basic common sense like don't
mix bleach with ammonia like there must
be some sort of thing already happening
to some degree
um because let's face it not everybody
does have common sense about these
things so I'm wondering do you know
either through Consultants or employees
that you or others may direct who
implements those things now
um it it's a good it's a good question I
think did your spouse work in fdm do I
remember that yes okay
I I try to Lodge a piece of information
in my brain every now and again
um the uh so we obviously
um occupational safety is is a is is a
concern of ours every day right and and
it takes different forms in different
places obviously uh computer workers
have have different uh things they look
at a lot of it involves we do regular
chair inspections for example
um and things like that whereas on our
point and property section where we have
you know hundreds of employees who are
doing uh uh doing more uh traditional
physical labor we have significant we do
trainings and and things like that all
the time
um in the budget we we uh transformed a
position into uh into a health and
safety officer so things like that do
happen and frankly in every Department
if you think about it I'm sure the you
know transportation for example probably
has a fairly robust program so a lot of
a lot of those things are happening
um they tend to be geared
along the lines of what do you do every
day and how do we make sure you don't
get back injuries for example
um you know we have uh workers comp
Consultants who work with
um you know from our insurance carrier
who work uh periodically with agencies
on you know these things as simple as
the proper way to lift a box to not get
back injuries they tend to work less
with me because I I lift fewer boxes
than average at least not heavy ones
um but
um so a lot of that is going on I don't
know that for the most part those things
would be repurposed because none of what
well none of none of what any of those
people are doing would we stop doing
right I mean we're still going to be
doing all of that kind of stuff but but
no there's a there's a lot that does go
on
thank you commissioner
seeing how we have uh
no one else who wants to speak to the
committee
my thinking is that uh rep Cole come and
I guess
avelini and infantine will have to
do some scheduling and I hate to do
scheduling with two important people not
in the room
um but um
after next week we're pretty much shut
down for July and August I would
anticipate getting back to to this in
September and scheduling a series of
meetings and inviting
um some of these interest groups in not
only the employers but the employee
Representatives that
match up with them so that we can get a
a clear picture of what they feel they
need in order to make this uh this
program work for for them
um
can I get a feel from reps Mackenzie
Susie and colcum as to what kind of
schedule you would want to uh set for um
I'm thinking in terms of weekly
bi-weekly
um you know do you want to hit it
aggressively and get it over with or do
you want to spread it out over September
are you allowed to have those over Zoom
no
I am out of town until September 7th
after that I can be flexible with my
schedule
will be hard but
other days we can certainly avoid
Mondays then
um the what I will plan to do is touch
base with um representatives evolini and
infantine next week we're obviously all
in on Thursday
um and um
find out what will work best and start
getting some emails to you folks to let
you know what the schedule is and then
get getting some invites out to these
various interest groups who may want to
come in and
get the information and
um
uh Deputy Commissioner perhaps
I can get a list together of people that
you can send the 1910 comparison uh file
to so that when people arrive they're
not uh
um I mean if if we tell them about it
when they get here they haven't had a
chance to do much of anything with it
and I think
Mr Ross has experience that it's a a bit
of an undertaking
um so it's uh something you'd want to
have well in advance I I was frankly
quite surprised when I first opened it
um and and somewhat baffled because we
we had three files and you know two of
them were very similar and it just uh
you know but boiling it down to just
1910 I think will help and I think some
of these groups will be able to look at
it and say this doesn't apply to me I'm
not even going to open it
um so I did I think a lot of the groups
can simply pick and choose those areas
that are relevant to their area of work
if you're in a nursing home you don't
have to do the heavy equipment section
um well maybe you do a little bit
what do I know so
so anyways um unless there's something
else that we need to discuss
um
McKenzie's gone
um okay well we will um bring this to a